just in case you mistake it for point
antiguo Kentucky yes there's a gigantic
lightning filled space tornado 50 feet
in front of you and if you can all agree
that driving into it is definitely the
smartest move it's 965 ad when the frost
giants did battle with the Asgardians on
planet earth that's like only a thousand
years ago we don't have any record of
that whatsoever no one wrote anything
down I mean looked up Plato's works and
that believed 1,400 years before this
Asgard is such a beautiful realm filled
with gorgeous CGI so long entrusted with
the mighty hammer Mjolnir its power has
no equal well except for the Iron Man
suit in the Avengers and Hulk in THE
AVENGERS and Loki's spear later on in
this very movie hey Thor is really angry
after his dad bitchslaps him in the
weapons vault but he waits until he's
all the way back home to express that
anger I mean how can he be so in control
of his emotions that he can travel all
the way back home without crushing and
breaking something but also be so out of
control that he has to upend a table in
his own home to feel better Wow
this room is like a shrine dat nipples
and telling me he didn't get one speck
of blood or saliva or frost beast brains
on him who shall ever hold to this
hammer if he be worthy Oh de Nimes it up
to the hammer to determine the
definition of worthy I mean could it
decide to give itself to James Worthy so
where's the correct window from when you
hit bore Natalie Portman isn't making
out with Mila Kunis in this scene this
town's name means ancient bridge the
Spanish explored New Mexico in the 16th
century so even if the town was founded
back then someone would have had to
remember the story of the battle between
the frost giants and Asgard that
happened in 10th century Norway the one
no one ever bothered to write down in
the history books either that or it's
just a huge coincidence that the town
named ancient bridge is where the
Rainbow Bridge connects to earth which
would be stupid yeah one of you hung
this picture on the board without
noticing the mane shape in it
Odin must have forgotten to take away
Thor's just as impressive Houdini powers
so no one was watching Thor after he
took on the entire hospital and the
police were called to investigate Luffy
solves the how are they gonna find Thor
problem by having him wander aimlessly
behind the van as it's moving also after
the big fighting incident how's he just
get up and walk out of the hospital with
no one seeing him
complete with this patient scrubbed and
everything oh okay so Loki is a smaller
frost giant that Odin adopted as his own
son it all makes sense now
wait how can you look human again hey
how's the quality of that furniture they
sell down there in Puente Antigua that's
just okay are you honestly trying to
tell me that a town of 2,000 people can
sustain a PC gaming business I lived in
a town of 2,000 people and these would
be thrilled to have a stoplight in a
7-eleven they ain't got no PC gaming
cafe okay this town is home of the
Vikings an appropriate mascot everyone
remembers those old tales where Eric the
Red sailed the Gulf of Mexico and shaped
everything we know about the western
United States I know this scientist the
Pioneer in gamma radiation we're not
saying his name though because honestly
we're all just trying to forget those
two movies this town of 2000 might have
a pet store but even if they did they
would not so grossly overstock the
puppies they're basically sentencing
half these puppies to death by ordering
so many fur town this small wait a
second they said goodbye to Thor and
then went and found shields stealing all
their stuff and then sat on the roof for
a while and moaned about it and then
went to the library to look up
information and only now has Thor ask
someone for a horse was he doing for the
last hour in a town that's two blocks
wide they said it was 50 miles to the
hammer site and while Jane and Thor were
driving there it's broad daylight and
then they try and sneak in a quick
sunset shot right at the end but do
their faces in this shot look bathed in
sunset glow no no they do not and then
when we cut back to them after a quick
Asgard visit it's the dead of night the
Sun has moved like 12 hours were the
distance in 50 miles super top secret
government alien meteorite site
guarded by no one and completely
approachable wait they're monitoring the
airspace but not the dirt roads right
outside their walls oh I see they only
care about security once it's already
been breached
got it nobody saw a big blonde dude
approaching they're tearing up the fence
around a highly secure area
even though the hammer is putting out
tons of electromagnetic energy and
causing cellphone reception to go crazy
and she's in the middle of the desert
Jane can still make a phone call with no
problem this mud wrestling scene is
sadly free of both hot female co-stars
alright movie introduces Hawkeye and he
does Jack this establishing shot brought
to you by Southwest Airlines if you're
Loki and you're basically hiding
yourself while you're here why bother to
wear a suit and tie movie just asks us
to accept that Loki can be invisible
without any
my explanation of his abilities says
here that he's an MD well he is or he
was Olsen obviously doesn't believe
Eric's stupid story and Thor just got
finished breaking into a government site
and beat up a bunch of his men but he
lets him go so they can follow him to
that evil lair of astrophysicists they
already know about now though he goes to
the frost giants wearing his usual
low-key wardrobe did he bring a change
of clothes with him while he was
transporting roamed around kashi Joleen
crunch a new telescope thor speaks
english but somehow thinks hubble is
pronounced hooble either that or he
believes mispronouncing it will lead to
a moment with Jane and she'll have sex
with him later deserve fine
did you say Anaheim and Disneyland is
more magical than I thought and show my
brother has not retired
why does look he tell the destroyer to
keep Thor from coming back to Asgard
when he was just gonna sack the
gatekeeper anyway
movies not interested in showing us if
lo you can see what the destroyer sees
or if he can see things telepathically
or if he's just guessing so wait does
Loki have control over the destroyer all
the way back at ass guard then why did
he command it to destroy everything if
he had control all along hero has to die
to prove his worthiness cliche man if
there had just been some attack that the
destroyer could have used other than
that we could punch he could have
stopped this before it started
just one other attack I can't think of
right now maybe future destroyers will
have better capabilities this war
between the gods in the middle of the
small town just makes things a little
dusty no other real damage occurs even
though there were tornado like winds and
explosions what Loki just kept behind
all standing here and ice and never once
thought that could backfire if you are
gonna kill the guy you should have at
least moved into storage or a mortal
jail or something that will return to
you except when I'm hanging out with the
Avengers I might be too busy then let's
talk about Loki's plan
it's totally dumb the whole plan
revolves around tricking the frost
giants to come to Asgard so that he can
pull the rug out from under them then
destroy them all thereby winning his
father's love and become the true king
of Asgard but he makes huge mistakes
unbecoming of an immortal first why even
bother with Thor even if Thor gets his
hammer back the whole key to him getting
back to Asgard is Heimdall whom he froze
and stupidly left at the Bifrost gate
secondly how does he explain all this to
Odin when he recovers I totally sent the
destroyer down to kill for and I
loyal and honest gatekeeper humble but
hey I killed all those frost giants that
you banished Thor for trying to kill him
because they totally snuck in and tried
to kill you
how'd they get here Heimdall did it I'm
sure you can use one of the other
passages between realms that you told
Heimdall about earlier in that you've
been using yourself throughout the movie
can you see huh yes hey can you tell me
what she's wearing who should we get to
direct this superhero movie I know well
we can't get Matthew Vaughn so we might
as well get that guy who directed all
those Shakespeare movies and credits
scene wasted on stupid setup for
Avengers tesseract storyline
well I guess that's worth look wait what
Loki is controlling this dude I mean
yeah and the Avengers he taps chests and
controls people even the same doctor
dude but he hasn't done that yet has he
don't they get a blue glaze to their
eyes when they're under Loki's
mind-control spell who led you into the
most glorious
forgotten all that we have done together
Fandral okay you did the vaults tag and
you brought up on the women I did true
but I supported you SIF
okay Ringo you win yours opening so I
think yes mm-hmm